today is day two of hybrid learning
wrapping up for the second wave of clark
county school district students
returning this week
some are noticing an issue with the new
schedule for grades 6
9 and 12. 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond showing us the concern
back on campus it's been great
absolutely wonderful honestly i
didn't know how much i needed this
students at las vegas academy of the
arts
welcome taking their classes in person
again after a year of distance education
i just came back because i wanted at
least a little bit of my senior year as
like
kind of underwhelming as it is but the
new hybrid schedule remains a concern
for bella whitmarsh
students only attend their morning
classes in person and leave campus to
log on remotely in the afternoon a
challenge for some teens
in after school activities who need a
place to finish their lessons
i'm a technical theater crew for our
musical something rotten so i have to
return to school at 2 30
but i live like 45 minutes away so i
can't drive home
it's just unrealistic when students
leave campus they're finding various
places to access wi-fi
including the writer's block here it's
kind of like all of these teenagers like
running around downtown las vegas so um
yesterday i went to container park and i
did my classes there the hybrid
implementation guide says
schools need to determine a location for
students participating in athletics or
activities to sit and work on
asynchronous instruction
while waiting for school activities or
events lva students
including brooklyn baca tell me they're
unaware of a designated spot on campus
if they set it up i'm sure we could do
it but right now it's just not set up
yet
until it happens baca and whitmarsh plan
to find safe locations around school
kristin drummond 8 news now thanks for
that kristen in a statement ccsd says
parents need to contact schools directly
if space is needed for that gap between
in-person learning
and any extracurricular activities all
secondary schools should have
a designated location tough for parents
too with all the back and forth back and
forth